♪ ♪
>> Tucker: CANADA HAS BECOME
JUST THE SECOND COUNTRY IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD TO FULLY
LEGALIZE THE SALE OF MARIJUANA
AS WELL AS THE RECREATIONAL
CONSUMPTION.
MUCH LIKE YOUNG AMERICANS, YOUNG
CANADIANS INCREASINGLY CAN'T
AFFORD TO BUY HOMES OR START
FAMILIES OR EVEN HAVE CARS.
MORE AND MORE OF THEM ARE STUCK
AT HOME LIVING WITH THEIR
PARENTS, WHOM THEY WILL MAKE
LESS THAN AS THEY GET OLDER.
THESE ARE HUGE PROBLEMS.
NO ONE IS EVEN THINKING ABOUT
HOW TO FIX THEM, BUT AT LEAST
YOUNG PEOPLE WILL BE TOO HIGH TO
NOTICE.
MAYBE THEY WON'T COMPLAIN.
IS THIS IDEA COMING TO
UNITED STATES?
OF COURSE IT IS.
SPOKESMAN FOR THE MARIJUANA
POLICY PROJECT, JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
DOES IT BOTHER YOU WHEN BIG
BUSINESS AND GOVERNMENT ALIGN TO
MAKE YOUNG PEOPLE MORE PASSIVE
AND COMPLIANT BACK >> WELL, IT
BOTHERS ME GOVERNMENT CREATES
FOOLISH LAWS THAT DESTROY THE
LIVES OF COUNTLESS YOUNG AND
OTHER PEOPLE OLDER PEOPLE ALIKE
FOR USING A SUBSTANCE THAT IS
OBJECTIVELY LESS HARMFUL THAN
ALCOHOL.
MARIJUANA IS OUT THERE.
SO RATHER THAN FORCING IT INTO
THE UNDERGROUND MARKET,
CRIMINALIZING PEOPLE FOR USING
IT, LET'S ACTUALLY CONTROL IT,
LET'S REGULATE IT, LET'S TREAT
IT MORE LIKE ALCOHOL AND DO WHAT
WE CAN TO MINIMIZE THE POTENTIAL
HARM AROUND IT.
>> Tucker: WE ARE NOT DOING
ANYTHING TO MINIMIZE THE HARM
AROUND IT, WE WILL NEVER DO THA
THAT.
IT'S BECOME MORE POTENT.
I WOULD CONCEDE THAT IT'S LESS
THREATENING THAN ALCOHOL FOR
SURE BUT IT'S ALSO LESS
DEADENING AND THAT'S KIND OF A
POINT ABOUT MARIJUANA.
IF THE GOVERNMENT ISN'T IN THE
MARIJUANA BUSINESS BECAUSE IT
WANTS TO MINIMIZE HARM.
IT WANTS TO MAKE MONEY AND TAX
REVENUE BUT IT ALSO WANTS TO
KEEP YOUNG PEOPLE PASSIVE AND
STUPID AND LESS LIKELY TO
COMPLAIN AND REVOLT WHEN THE
ECONOMY THEY CREATED DOESN'T
SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T SEE THIS?
>> I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY KIND OF
AN ABSURD NOTION SEEING AS
MARIJUANA HAS LONG BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH YOUNGER PEOPLE
REVOLTING.
MARIJUANA BECAME POPULAR IN THE
'60s DURING THE ANTIWAR
MOVEMENT.
>> Tucker: DO YOU SMOKE A LOT
OF WEED, MASON?
COME ON, I GREW UP IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT DOES NOT MAKE YOU MORE LIKELY
TO DO ANYTHING, IS THE TRUTH, AS
YOU KNOW.
I KNOW FIRSTHAND AND YOU KNOW
YOU DO TOO.
>> THAT'S A STEREOTYPE.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING EVERYONE
ENJOYS A COCKTAIL AFTER WORK
WITH THEIR FRIENDS IS A LUSH.
IT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT ARGUING
THAT.
>> IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
IF THE LAST FEW PRESIDENTS.
WE FED SUPREME COURT JUSTICES,
COUNTLESS BUSINESS PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM FOR ADULTS TO
USE IT RESPONSIBLY.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT ARGUING
THAT.
I'M NOT ARGUING IT IS A PROBLEM
FOR PEOPLE TO SMOKE MARIJUANA
OCCASIONALLY.
I'M NOT A PROHIBITIONIST BITE AT
I'M NOT A PROHIBITIONIST BITE AA
I'M NOT A PROHIBITIONIST BITE AL
I'M NOT A PROHIBITIONIST BITE A.
IT'S TRUE OF EVERYTHING.
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT WHAT WE
ARE SEEING.
WASHINGTON, OREGON, NEVADA,
EVERY STATE THAT HAS MADE
MARIJUANA LEGAL HAS NOT SEEN AN
INCREASE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THAT'S FAKE NUMBERS.
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT A FACT.
>> TALK TO THE GOVERNMENTS IN
EACH OF THOSE STATES.
>> Tucker: LET ME JUST ASK
YOU.
OVERPOPULATION'S, IT IS TRUE
THAT MARIJUANA, AND THIS IS
A CLINICAL MATTER THAT HAS BEEN
STUDIED A LOT OVER DECADES,
MAKES PEOPLE LESS LIKELY TO ACT.
IT MAKES THEM MORE PASSIVE AND
I'M JUST SAYING IF YOU ARE
RUNNING A SYSTEM THAT WAS NOT
SERVING YOUNG PEOPLE, SERVING
THEM SO BADLY A LOT OF THEM
BECAME SOCIALISTS, WOULDN'T YOU
WANT THEM PASSIVE AND SPACEY AND
OUT OF IT AND WOULDN'T YOU ALSO
WANT TO COLLECT THE TAX REVENUE
AND CONTINUE YOUR LINES WITH
CREEPY BIG CANNABIS COMPANIES?
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT'S GOING ON,
RIGHT?
>> I THINK IT'S BIZARRE THAT YOU
WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO USE THIS
AS A WAY TO CRIMINALIZE A WHOLE
POPULATION OF PEOPLE AND CONTROL
PEOPLE.
IF YOU WANTED TO BE A CRIME FOR
ADULTS TO USE A SUBSTANCE LESS
HARMFUL THAN ONE THAT IS LEGAL T
HARMFUL THAN ONE THAT IS LEGAL O
YOU OR ME OR ANYONE.
>> Tucker: WHAT I'M SAYING IS
MARIJUANA ARE EFFECTIVELY
ALREADY WAS DECRIMINALIZED IN
MOST PLACES.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO DO JAIL
TERMS FOR WEED.
>> HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS ARE ARRESTED FOR EVERY
YEAR FOR MARIJUANA.
>> Tucker: NO ONE IN MOST
PLACES IS ARRESTED FOR A
JOINT -- WE HAD A DON'T ASK
DON'T TELL POLICY IN A LOT OF
PLACES.
>> HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS ARE ARRESTED EVERY
YEAR FOR MARIJUANA.
>> Tucker: BUT HOLD ON.
YOU COULD VERY EASILY, IN
EFFECT, DECRIMINALIZE IT FOR
SMALL AMOUNTS WITHOUT
LEGALIZING, WHICH MEANS EVERY
TIME I WALK THROUGH TIMES SQUAR
TIMES SQUARE, SOMEONE IS HITTING
A VAPE OR SMOKING A JOINT, WHICH
IS WHAT IT IS NOW.
I'M SAYING IT'S A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT THING.
AS YOU KNOW.
BUT BIG OPENINGS WANT TO PROFIT
FROM THIS.
>> DON'T YOU SEE WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING?
IT'S ILLEGAL IN TIMES SQUARE.
>> Tucker: I'M SAYING IT'S
ARTIE BEEN DECRIMINALIZED AS YOU
KNOW.
IN NEW YORK CITY,
WASHINGTON, D.C., PEOPLE SMOKE
ON THE STREET.
>> IF YOU DO YOU'RE GOING TO GET
CITED.
THE SAME IF YOU HAVE A BEER ON
THE STREET.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
NOTHING HAPPENS TO YOU WHEN YOU
SMOKE WEED IN NEW YORK.
>> IF YOU CAN PROVE IT'S ILLEGAL
TO USE MARIJUANA ON THE STREETS.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE MISSING MY
POINT.
IT'S NOT ENFORCED.
de BLASIO JUST SAID TO THE
COPS, I JUST TALKED ABOUT IT.
THAT'S BETTER THAN LEGALIZING
IT.
THE ONLY THING THAT WILL DO IS
MAKE IT MORE COMMON.
>> YOU ARE DENYING THE FACTS.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE DENYING
REALITY.
>> THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ARE ARRESTED IN NEW YORK
EVERY YEAR FOR MARIJUANA
POSSESSION.
IT'S JUST A FACT.
YOU THINK OF THIS CONSPIRACY TO
DUMB DOWN AMERICA.
>> Tucker: IS LITERALLY THAT
BUT IT'S ALSO A CONSPIRACY FOR
PEOPLE LIKE YOU TO GET RICH FROM
SELLING IT.
LET'S BE HONEST, THIS IS BIG
CORPORATIONS TRYING TO GET RICH
FROM KIDS SMOKING MORE WEED.
I'M SURE YOU'VE GOT A PIECE OF
IT.
DON'T GIVE IN OUR PERSONAL
FREEDOM GARBAGE.
IF THIS IS CORPORATION.
>> DO YOU THINK IT SHOULD BE --
TO THINK ANHEUSER-BUSCH IS AN
EVIL CORPORATION AND THAT THEY
ARE JUST OUT THERE TO DESTROY
THE WORLD?
>> Tucker: NOT TO DESTROY THE
WORLD.
>> DO THINK THAT ALCOHOL SHOULD
BE ILLEGAL AND THAT THESE
COMPANIES SHOULD NOT BE THERE TO
PROVIDE A PRODUCT?
>> Tucker: A PRODUCT, IT'S
JUST A PRODUCT.
NO, IT DESTROYS PEOPLE.
I'VE SEEN IT.